we bring in Albert Breer senior NFL
reporter the Monday Morning Quarterback
who joins us and by the looks of your
room there you love yourself some Ohio
State Buckeyes there it's just by
accident that Paulie wore his Michigan
t-shirt today are you a Michigan guy
Paulie I couldn't have gotten in the
Michigan if you doubled my GPA no I went
to southern Iowa I got an even better
story I come from a long line of
Michigan people and I couldn't get in so
I went to arrival yeah that but but
where did you grow up are you from
Michigan no I'm from Massachusetts my
dad's from Detroit though and so my
dad's side of the family is almost
entirely from Michigan everybody went to
Michigan or Michigan State and yeah I
was the black sheep I went to the other
Big Ten school yeah but people call this
a rivalry and I'm from Ohio and I say
it's not a rivalry because Michigan is
not on the same level and so hyoe state
we yeah what do you think of that it's
not it's to me over the last 17 18 yeah
I mean it's like when I was in school
there Dan it was the tail end of the
Lloyd Carr John Cooper thing and it's
amazing what's happened and I think it
honestly I think because it matters more
to people in Ohio that's why things have
gone the way they've gone but I mean
yeah I mean from what trestle is done
the fact that they've been more dominant
since the after trust a lot some believe
yeah but why does it matter more to how
State fans than it does Michigan fans I
don't know you're probably as good to
answer that as I am right because you're
from there
I don't know I mean I think it's just
more I just think it's more ingrained in
the culture in Ohio and I think the
other thing is I mean when I went to
school to Ohio State I don't know it's
still the same way there but I think 95%
of the people that I went to school with
were from Ohio and Michigan a lot of the
people didn't grow up with it I mean a
lot of the people that they go to
Michigan are from New York from
California and so I think it's a little
less ingrained in the people who went to
Michigan than it is people eyes yeah but
I think when you're with it everybody
loves a winner therefore it's more
important to Ohio fans because they're
on the winning side of this whereas
Michigan fans not as excited you know
that's sort of downplaying this
maybe maybe that's why it means more I
don't know I don't know though exactly
Dan they ran off John Cooper because he
couldn't beat Michigan like John Cooper
was fine otherwise and they ran him off
simply because he couldn't beat Michigan
so but everything's good now you know
hiyo is downplaying the rivalry when it
wasn't going well for them well the fact
that it is going well that you know they
don't they're not everything you know
they're fine with their coach because
whoever their coaches because they know
that Michigan's coaches Jim Harbaugh and
they always feel like they have the
upper hand there do you see a scenario
where Harbaugh eventually leaves
Michigan for another coaching job I mean
I think he certainly wants to take
another crack at the NFL I do think that
he has some unfinished business there I
I honestly think it's sort of bothered
him you know the way that he like his
brother finally his brother got to the
mountaintop against him and you know
I've always felt like there was that
that little piece of unfinished business
so I don't know how long he's gonna stay
at Michigan I know a lot of people felt
like you know he'd probably be at
Michigan for four or five years then go
back because he's been sort of a
short-term or the other places he's been
so he's already sort of lasted longer
than some people thought he'd last at
Michigan I think you'll eventually be
back in the NFL Smasher why do you think
Ohio State fans won Jim Harbaugh to stay
as head coach at Michigan I mean right
now I'd say yeah coaching him he's
beating him on the field I like the fact
that not just Urban Meyer beat Jim
Harbaugh this way the fact that Ryan
day's beating him this way too and has
all the momentum III know this there's
just seems to be a lot of unlocked
potential left in that Michigan program
and it's super interesting to me the
idea that like you know the rod that
another coach could come in here and
after the urban Harbaugh thing
take Ohio State to another level and now
Jim Harbaugh has got to catch up to him
it'll be interesting to see where it
goes
right Albert Brewer joining a senior NFL
reporter mm QB now let's talk about your
day job here I was all excited about sky
judge I really was and now it's being
tabled why is it being tabled and is the
replay official getting some more
responsibilities well it's not really be
I mean it's being tabled but it's being
tabled and
it was written by the coaches
subcommittee and in particular that the
Ravens coach John Harbaugh and the
Chargers coach Anthony Lin and and the
difference between what they wanted to
do and what's going to be going in in an
experimental basis is really about who
the sky judge himself is and the coaches
really wanted it to be a more
experienced guy so either a retired head
referee or a more experienced member of
the crew with younger guys becoming the
eighth member of the crew they really
wanted an experienced hand up there's
somebody that everybody could trust be
in charge of monitoring the broadcast
and being in charge of having that view
up top you know and and and really the
league wasn't ready to take that step
and so while Anderson who's become very
involved over the last four or five
months he was non field official until
the end of the season he's moved into a
senior role in the NFL office now
he sort of suggested hey listen the
replay officials we have are good will
change out a few of them and we'll get
some good guys in here and then let's
give this a shot in the preseason and if
it works in the preseason let's try it
in the regular season and if it works in
the regular season we can expand on it
in 2021 and so there's been a two-year
process for guys like John Harbaugh and
Andy Reid Nancy Lin and all these guys
really just want to give the officials a
resource and the idea was to give them a
high-end resource by giving them an
experienced official up top this is sort
of the compromise for the replay
official the existing replay official
will have expanded you I don't know if
you saw the comments Dean Blandino made
on the show a couple of days ago where
he said when he was in charge of the
officials there was a break glass in
case of emergency where New York would
contact the official on the field and
say guys huddle up because as Dean said
you know we were worried about something
extreme historically bad or
controversial here we contacted the NFL
the NFL said we have no comment and then
I talked to a source who said that's the
way Dean did things not the way we do
things now what do you make of that well
Dean was very close with a lot of the
coaches and he had that trust with the
coaches Dan and that's one thing that
came up I think that's been lost the
last couple of years
was a lot of the respect between the
coaches in the league office was built
by team Blandino and so when Dean went
into TV I do think a little bit of that
was lost which is where some of the
issues have come in the last couple of
years I can also say this like the sky
judge it with certain crews has actually
already existed and so I'll give you a
great example everybody remembers the
Earl Thomas hit on Mason Rudolph last
year right so if you guys go back and
watch that broadcast go pull it up on
game pass or whatever watch one they cut
to commercial after Mason Rudolph goes
down there's no flag on the field when
they come back from commercial there is
a flag on the field
it took about 35 to 40 seconds for the
flag to go on the field well what
happened there well John Harbaugh went
over to the head referee says we'll wait
a second where'd that flag come from and
the head officials said to him the guy
up in the booth told me to drop it
because the hit was egregious and
Harbaugh said to the head official oh
you mean like a sky judge so they've
actually been sort of using some of
these things in spots over the last
couple of years I think the way that
what the coaches really wanted was to
formalize that make sure everybody had
the benefit of it and again this isn't
coaches versus officials the main thing
for these coaches was giving the
officials the benefit that every single
one of us sitting at home with the cable
subscription has which is eight ten
twelve different angles of crystal-clear
HD to see everything from ie these
coaches really thought it was crazy that
the guys in the field weren't getting
the the benefit that tens of millions of
people have sitting on their couches
every day yeah the people who are in
charge to make these calls have the
worst view we have the best view so
right why not take advantage of that to
help them I still don't understand the
San Saints Rams call non call the fact
that there were two fouls
including helmet to helmet were not
called that's where I thought and Dean
Blandino was not in the Home Office in
New York to be able to hate guys huddle
up because I think they did huddle up
and they still missed it so how do you
prevent that when we get to the
postseason when you have all-star crews
well I think and one thing that actually
was brought up to me I didn't know this
yeah maybe you're aware of this because
you've been honest who
broadcast did you know that there are
extra officials on a sideline during the
Superbowl to have headsets on and
they're communicating with the head
referees no like I didn't even know that
like you know over the last couple of
days I'm making phone calls on this I
sort of learned that and and really it's
like you said Dan they're trying to give
more resources to these guys and so you
know the idea is the head referees still
in charge of the game but there's a guy
up top and that guy has access to the
broadcast that guy's also watching from
the booth so he has that vantage point
and so he's gonna be able to communicate
with the head referee the head referee
doesn't have to do anything like this
guy doesn't have the the guy up top
doesn't have the authority to stop the
game he can't throw a flag he can't do
any of that but within the first 15
seconds of the play clock he can buzz
down now I'll ask you like in that
stance Rams game it didn't take 15
seconds for all of us know was the wrong
call right yeah in that case in that
case the guy up top would have called
down to the head referee where I said
drop the flag the ref would have dropped
the flag because he trusts the guy up
top and we would have had a penalty the
Saints would have had a first down and
maybe going to the Super Bowl and so
it's just it's giving them that resource
where it's not about getting every every
single judgment call right it's about
getting the black and white white ones
that we know are wrong corrected and you
know I think that this is an efficient
way to do it it may take a year or two
for them to work out the kinks and get
the right people up top but it's really
really important to these coaches that
they at least start that process in 2020
the onside kick where do we stand with
them so they there have been some
unintended consequences that have come
up here and I think what's interesting
about it was most interesting about it
to me Dan is that this is a rule that
they haven't even put in yet and they're
already having to fill about where we're
going right
I mean like you look at it like baby so
we we could we now we'd have to have to
have this whole rule for a day before
everybody could realize that there were
issues with it so one they tied up you
know there was the thought okay like if
you have say to take the lead a a score
a touchdown I go up by four points
whatever I'm kicking off and there are
six seconds left in the game
well if I'm that team rather than
kicking it to the other team wouldn't I
just snap the ball into into fourth and
15 tell my quarterback to run around for
three seconds and throw it to the moon
like it would make sense to do that
right and so they've taken care of that
by making it an untimed down but I think
the fact that we're are any trouble
shooting their thing before it even goes
in at least makes me skeptical about how
this thing's gonna work listen I
understand it's the safety has even a
health and safety measure that they feel
like they've got to take kickoff and the
onside kicks out of the game and that's
all fine I understand that part of it
and I understand there's a fun thing for
everybody to talk about but it does make
me a little bit I guess you're skeptical
over the whole thing that they're
already having a trouble shoot it before
it even goes in three years do we have
kickoffs in the NFL I think we do but I
think they're gonna look different and I
honestly like if I were the league I
would have taken the XFL idea and I
would have just implemented it in the
preseason and see how it works
I mean look like I can tell you most
coaches I've talked to a really
protective of that phase of the game
that really believed that it should
remain in the game that it's a part of
the game and that you be bastardizing
the game by taking it out of it so I
know a lot of the special teams coaches
have done a lot of hard work to try to
preserve the kickoff as best they can
it's hard to do it but you know I think
the XFL found an effective way to sort
of attack this and I mean to me it was
inventive it was fun it didn't totally
take the idea to kickoff away you still
have to kickoff return touchdowns so I
know that's one they've discussed I'm
surprised they didn't at least maybe
look at the idea of implementing it for
the preseason I'd expect it'll get more
discussion in 2020 I don't understand
that you'd want to take away the the
onside kick because you don't want
another collision or collisions but then
you're gonna have the marquee players
who were gonna come back out on the
field for a fourth and 15 I would rather
have the onside kick off team then back
up linebackers then I would
I got Patrick mahomes back there for a
fourth and 15 with the marquee players
on the wide you know on the offense and
then the defense you know it's a pass I
I don't know you're asking for contact
there as well I mean is it a pass
interference down to that's the other
thing
I mean fourth and 15 or do you have a
better shot of converting that by just
throwing it up to
Julio Jones and hoping somebody Yanks on
his Jersey you know what I mean well
there are certain things like that that
could come into play too I actually
talked to one coach and this may be a
little conspiracy theory ish but there
are some coaches that feel like the NFL
is you know actively look to try to take
the middle class out of the league and
who's the middle class well the middle
class is guys like Matt Slater on the
Patriots who are making 3-4 million
dollars a year and who are playing what
like probably six or eight plays a game
and so you know there are there are I
think there is a feeling that there may
be are there are some ulterior motives
here on the part of the owners I don't
know how much truth there is to that but
but certainly I think that there are
coaches that really feel like the
kickoff is they've done a lot of work to
try to keep the kickoff as is and they
really should try not to bastardize it
come on I'll leave you with this
Jadeveon Clowney still on the outside
looking in with maybe Tennessee maybe
back to Seattle the Cleveland Browns
offered a great deal which I was
surprised you have miles Garrard you're
gonna have to pay him but where does
Jadeveon Clowney fit with either of
these three teams yeah I always thought
his best option was to go back to
Seattle just because I thought that was
the best chance for him to have a great
year you know he's one of these guys who
sort of caught up in the fact that he
can't take a physical there is some
instability in his knee I know teams
that were interested really wanted to
have their own doctors get their hands
on him obviously that's not possible
given the circumstances you know then
there are questions about his
personality he really wore out his
welcome in Houston that's another reason
why the team's gonna sign him to a big
deal they'd want him to come in and talk
to them and so those have been issues I
think his financial expectations were
certainly an issue he saw guys like
Frank Clark and DeMarcus Lauren Scott
and you know he just shot too high early
on so I think his best bet right now is
to find a place where he can go on a
one-year deal and go to a place where
you know this games familiar Cleveland
scheme they weren't a Seattle type of
scheme scheme to be familiar they're
Seattle of course if they'd have him
back if he could work away to do a
one-year deal there even if it was flus
money I think it'd be smart as he poised
to have a big year there and then of
course the other one to keep an eye on
was the Tennessee Titans because of his
relationship with my variable yeah this
is Cleveland's got 37 million dollars
to spend here right is that why are why
didn't they spend it earlier information
I mean remember who's running the team
there too Dan I mean I like I come hell
or high water they're going online on
the analytics model you can see in the
people that they've hired you can see it
in kind of the way they've set that
organization up Paul DePodesta has a lot
of power in that organization and the
way analytics work in every sport right
you put values on people and you don't
really stray from that too much and so
even if you have money to spend if the
value is not there you're not going to
spend the money and so you know I think
the Browns will eventually wind up
spending but you look at the positions
they spend on I mean they go and get a
tackle tackle as a premium position so
they spent on on a Jack Conklin you know
I think really a lot of this boils down
to you know how their models are working
and where they're being kind of guided
to spend you know again like if you're
if you're working on and that sort of
setup generally you're gonna let value
drive you if you don't think the value
is there even if you do have the money
to spend
you're not going to over step speaking
of which dak Prescott yeah everybody
seems to be you know sitting on the edge
of their seats waiting for dak Prescott
to what are the options here July 15th I
mean to me July 15th is you know really
the date that I think we've all had our
eye on the whole time and deadlines spur
action and if you want to look at the
Cowboys history they've generally taken
care of all these guys you know Zack
Martin Jalen Smith's DeMarcus Lauren
Zeke Elliott Amari Cooper they take care
of their own guys there are very few
guys that they have not did they've
wanted to keep that they have not been
able to lock up long term the key here
though Dan's gonna be the length of the
deal just by sitting on his hands
okay just by doing nothing that Prescott
either gets 31 million dollars this year
and becomes a free agent at 27 70
million over the next two free agent at
28 or 120 million over the next three
and a free agent at 29 and so he doesn't
do anything have to do anything to
exercise one of those three options and
so the Cowboys have to convince them
they're putting something in front of
him that's good enough to walk away from
those three options they haven't done
that yet
and I still think the key to this deal
is going to be how long it is dak
Prescott would like a shorter deal
that'll allow them to go back to the
table in three or four years and
capitalize on all the new TV money the
gambling money coming into the league
the Cowboys would like to sign him to a
longer deal a five or a six year deal
like they did with Smith with Eliot with
horns yeah but it's amazing that dak
Prescott is making more money by not
doing anything by just just sitting like
his value keeps going up because you
know Deshawn Watson's what he's gonna
get paid well they're waiting for all of
this right and that's the thing like I
mean that's where you're playing with
fire for the Cowboys right Dan I mean
yes big ones sitting out there stashing
my homes you know if you I like like you
could sit here and say well God you know
forty million a year seems like a lot
for dak Prescott and then Pat mahomes
goes and signs a deal at 41 or 42 like
then what you know what like then then
that's just where the market is and so
you know I know a lot of people have
said it's you know it's tough for top to
swallow the idea of dak Prescott at
forty million dollars a year well I mean
we can go down the list of guys who were
the highest-paid players in the league
over the last four or five years was
derrick karr the best player in the
league was Jimmy Garoppolo the best
player in the league was was Matt Ryan
the best player in the league was Kirk
Cousins the best player in the league at
one point or another all of those guys
were the highest-paid player in football
it's just the way you pay quarterbacks
and so he's the next one table so he's
gonna be the highest-paid guy and again
I think it would behoove the Cowboys to
try and take care of this as soon as
they can so you don't wind up having to
pay a tax because they waited until
after Patrick mahomes the all-star thank
you for spending time Albert great stuff
yeah Thank You Albert Breer senior NFL
reporter for the Monday Morning
Quarterback